tja vor Monaten wäre das noch völlig
unvorstellbar gewesen der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck bringt
an zehn Standorten schmutzige alte
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz und eines
sticht dabei ganz besonders heraus und
zwar ja negativ man kann es eigentlich
nicht fassen aber es gehört tatsächlich
zu den acht klimaschädlichsten
Kraftwerken Europas ja man muss sagen
Hauptsache keine Atomkraft offenbar
Jens Walde es ist ein Kohlekraftwerk aus
einer anderen einer schmutzigen Zeit in
Betrieb genommen 1976 in der damaligen
DDR
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
der sich vehement gegen Atomkraftwerke
wehrt hat jetzt Block E dieses
Kraftwerks wieder ans Netz genommen
Jänschwalde eine absolute Dreckschleuder
zählt zu den acht klimaschädlichsten in
ganz Europa
Kohlendioxid Stickoxide schwefloxid
Arsen Quecksilber das Kraftwerk stößt
tonnenweise Gift aus eine wahre
horrorbilanz für Mensch und Umwelt aber
damit noch nicht genug das Kraftwerk
entnimmt mehr Grundwasser als
wasserrechtlich zulässig mitunter sogar
das Dreifache des Erlaubten die
Opposition ist entsetzt
ich bin davon überzeugt dass auch viele
grüne außerhalb unseres Landes sind ganz
Europa mit großer Verwunderung auf
Deutschland schauen dass wir
schmutzigste Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz
nehmen das ist auch notwendig in dieser
Situation es wird Kohle in Südafrika
beschafft auf der anderen Seite möchte
Harbeck stinkende ölkraftwerke auf den
Meeren laufen lassen das ist im Grunde
genommen die Stromerzeugung die
Energieerzeugung von Dritte Welt Ländern
das passt einfach nicht zusammen das
Kohlekraftwerk jenswalde mit Robert
Habeck nimmt ausgerechnet ein grüner
diese Dreckschleuder wieder ans Netz
obwohl es eine deutlich
klimaverträglichere Alternative gäbe
nämlich atomkraft
wir Grünen entdecken ihre Vorliebe für
Dreckschleudern darüber müssen wir
sprechen mit bildpolitik-chef Jan
Schäfer schönen guten Morgen Jan also
schwimmende Kraftwerke drecks schleudern
die jetzt plötzlich wieder ins Netz
genommen werden warum machthabeck das
irgendwie versteht man es nicht nein das
kann man nicht verstehen der Tat wir
haben einen Energiemangel an
energienotstand und in diesem Energie
Notstand ist diesem klimaschutzminister
Ideologie offenbar wichtiger als das
Klima es ist im Ideologie auch wichtiger
als die Gesundheit in das kleine
Beispiel und im Beitrag ja gerade eben
auch an Jens Wahl der eine absolute
Dreckschleuder und zwar für die Umwelt
aber auch für die Menschen für die
Gesundheit und wenn man sich auch Zahl
mal anschaut was Kohlekraft im Jahr
weltweit an Todesfällen verursacht also
das was dann an Abgasen an
beispielsweise auch Quecksilber in die
Luft geht dann ist das beträchtlich gibt
viele Untersuchungen und die kommen
eigentlich immer zu dem Ergebnis dass
Kernkraft viel viel sauberer viel viel
risikoarmer ist als die Kohlekraft und
deswegen ist umso merkwürdiger und
eigentlich auch völlig unverständlich
warum ausgerechnet der
klimaschutzminister jetzt auf diese
alten Dreckschleudern setzt und nicht
auf ziemlich saubere Atomkraft wie
diskutiert man das dann in der Partei
also steht die Partei noch hinter Robert
habe gerade nach diesen Entscheidungen
in der Partei gibt es ganz ganz viele
verschiedene Argumentationsstränge die
Grünen DNA ist ja wirklich das Anti
Atomkraft gehen dass sie innen drin
haben und dem ordnen Sie alles andere
unter und da gibt es ganz ganz viele
unterschiedliche Argumente eins ist
beispielsweise auch wenn man jetzt für
Atomkraft wäre bzw die Laufzeiten
deutlich länger beispielsweise bis 24
oder bis 25 verlängern würde dann gibt
es die Sorge dass dann der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien also von Wind und
Sonne in gewisser Weise gebremst würde
dann gibt es immer das Argument des
Endlagers aber das sind natürlich alles
Argumente die andere Länder gelöst haben
das heißt Deutschland befindet sich in
einer Situation auch angerufen durch die
Politik der Grünen besonders
hervorgerufen durch die Politik der
Grünen was eine Sonderrolle ist und es
hilft manchmal der Blick ins Ausland das
ist gar nicht so schlecht und man könnte
auch Robert Habeck wünschen genau das zu
tun jetzt schaut man mal auf die Ampel
und auf die Partner in dieser Koalition
die FDP ist ja nun vehement dagegen was
bedeutet dieser Zoff jetzt für den
Zustand der Ampel die FDP ist dagegen
das ist wird immer jetzt so gesagt gegen
was ist die FDP genau die FDP ist
dagegen dass im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres
bereits zwei Kernkraftwerke dann auch
endgültig von Netz gehen wie ist die
Situation eigentlich sollten Ende dieses
Jahres alle drei deutschen Meiler
endgültig vom Netz jetzt hat Robert
Habeck gesagt okay wir können uns
vorstellen zwei bis Mitte April laufen
zu lassen und da sagt die FDP nein das
ist zu kurz wir müssen sie eigentlich
bis 2024 laufen lassen vielleicht sogar
noch länger dass der Streit um den es
geht da gab es gestern Abend auch eine
krisenschalte Robert Habeck der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und Christian
Lindner aus Washington zugeschaltet
haben sich ausgetauscht noch mal mit
Energieversorger nach allem was wir
bisher wissen gab es bei dem Gespräch
aber keinen neuen Sachstand bzw auch
keine Entscheidung und ja es gibt Druck
die Grünen haben ab heute ihren
Parteitag der geht bis Sonntag und da
wird über das Thema Kernkraft natürlich
auch noch mal massiv diskutiert wir sind
sehr gespannt wie das Ganze auf jeden
Fall ausgehen wird da dürfte es
hochhergehen heute danke schön ja
[Musik]